hello
I forgot to turn my screensaver off so
give me a second yay okay so I'm here
today to talk to you about the Internet
of cats or trying new things is scary my
name is Rachel white I'm oh ho on
Twitter I'm a front-end engineer at IBM
Watson and I live in New York so let's
go this is me I love cats it might be
hard to see I can't see that screen
right now but um this is in Tokyo last
fall at a cat cafe and I am covered in
about eight different cats that just so
happened to blend in with the couch it
was one of the happiest moments of my
life and I I've always kind of liked
cats and tried to have ideas of like how
can I incorporate cats into technology
um but trying new things is scary and
I'm mostly a front-end person like I
don't do hardware for my job I don't
really do back end except now because
they're making me and I can't really
argue with them um so I was like okay
how am I going to put this together and
I decided to think of ways that I could
try something new the ways that I think
that trying things that are new or scary
is like you're trying something new from
the beginning it's a totally new project
you don't know how it's going to turn
out maybe it'll suck maybe nobody like
it maybe it won't even work who knows
using new technologies for the first
time is always scary to like you don't
know if all the documentation is there
you don't know if people are going to be
there to be available to help you out
you just you don't really know what's
going to happen also scary is
contributing to open source in general
and I knew that I wanted to contribute
an open source but I was afraid of all
of the negativity around close
communities and stuff and I was like how
am I going to do this pretty much like
putting yourself out there in general is
pretty terrifying let's talk about why
it's scary for a little bit um like I
said you know maybe people laid it
maybe they won't like your project maybe
they'll think your code sucks maybe
they'll think you're stupid if they're
jerks and think that that matters
imposter syndrome sucks like are you
even good enough to finish this project
like will you be able to handle the code
if it's something that you're not
particularly familiar with and the
inclusiveness of communities I see this
happen more with smaller projects that
have a certain amount of contributors
that have always been contributing to it
and if somebody comes in and wants to
change something sometimes I'll just get
ignored or sometimes people just will be
be very receptive to the feedback a bad
behavior in open source in general and
in tech I've seen a lot of people on
github lately that are just the
equivalent of a Twitter egg where
they're anonymous they don't provide
anything really productive other than
complaining about terminology code
conducts that kind of stuff which gets
me into people complaining about code of
conducts existing which if you're a good
person you shouldn't complain about that
obviously um so some examples of bad
behavior that I've seen our feigned
ignorance uh which is I've encountered
in jobs before where instead of giving
constructive criticism if something
doesn't if somebody doesn't know
something that you just go oh you didn't
know about this like you should have
known instead of just telling you about
it so you don't have to ask again
completely ignoring contributions and
open source stuff so if somebody you
know takes the time to want to
contribute to something that you're a
part of and you just ignore them it's
not going to make them want to
participate in the future which isn't a
way to grow communities alternately for
maintainer is a demanding user base
which if you notice I've talked to a
couple people about this as soon as
somebody open sources a new project
usually the the first like slow of open
pull requests or issues will be people
complaining about spelling grammar they
don't like the way that certain things
are done and just like complaining in
general in
of being happy that there's something
new for them to try and also useless
pull requests for the sake of a green
timeline you don't need to be that
person that makes the first pull request
fixing a couple commas and periods just
for the sake of like commenting first on
a post it's like your github timeline is
not an indicator of your self-worth and
I really wish that more people would
realize that also insulting the
contributor uh I don't even know why
this I have to say this it makes no
sense you shouldn't insult people that
are trying to be productive just don't
do it or disagreeing over trivial things
by trivial things I guess it's not
really trivial but there's been a lot of
stuff lately with people complaining
about wanting to change terminology and
get rid of the master-slave terminology
which is completely warranted and you
shouldn't argue over it if it's still
going to function the same way but not
make people uncomfortable so when I was
like starting on this project and
wanting to get involved in open source
and see how other people that I interact
with which are mostly women in tech I
polled on Twitter to see what kind of
experiences people have and I'm just
going to read them to Jen shipper said
vulgar and brutal harassment expectation
and entitlement of your time without any
compensation offered the next one is
unfortunately the harassment was enough
for me to stop trying before I had other
problems so that's where I met so they
didn't even get to the point where they
were contributing because of the
harassment in general this next one's
anonymous because they didn't even want
to be attached for fear of further
harassment entitlement of time the
assumption you immediately want feedback
when you're just starting nerd pedantic
and obstructing learning a co-worker of
mine and friend Caroline said
mansplaining mainly in a general fear
that any commit I make will be open as
an issue
debated about Caroline's involved a lot
with like security stuff and she has a
legit reason for being afraid because
she has gotten doxxed and your family
has gotten swatted it's like not cool
that these things happen and the next
one is sent a pull request with bug
fixes that got ignored for almost a year
after which the maintainer wrote the
same fixes and said oops next is Tess
who also said mansplaining my own code
to me and trolling Tess is pretty
relevant because she open source
something a little bit last year called
echo chamber j/s which is all of the
commenting none of the comments what it
is is it's a third-party script that you
add to your website that utilizes local
storage with your comments form so all
the people that want to say garbage will
post hit that send button it'll store
locally on their machine and look at the
feel proud of themselves for being an
[ __ ] that nobody else ever has to see
it which is really awesome and uh when
she made this which is clearly like not
serious more of like social commentary
on internet comments she got trolled
this this awesome kind gentleman with
the Steve Jobs I calm it says I dead
opened a pull request or an issue that
says you're fat and then they were like
that's not enough so they changed it
from your fat to your fat and insecure
and then another one from ghost too I
believe is one of those people that only
complains on repositories and maybe like
commits to some things I'm going to read
this whole thing because it's really sad
I'll read it maybe I'll be quick web
development or web design does have a
psychological part besides the technical
part and this library is intended to
give the illusion to the user that he
and gate he engages with the website by
commenting it it clearly has the intent
or to do poor trick the end user as no
indication is given that his or her
message will not be sent through the
network I'm I'll skip the next one and
it says such library seems to rise
epical concerns about the relationship
between the maintainer of the
site and the end user it is promoting
relationships based on duping another
that is a form of irresponsibility and
indifference is it any good just asking
to myself and I'm going to go ahead and
answer him and say no nobody was you
[ __ ] and you shouldn't feel entitled to
even say this stuff so when coming for a
new project my proposal for new
contributors which is something that I
did myself is find something you're
passionate about for me it's cats in a
totally healthy way I swear or something
new that you want to try it for me it
was hardware and some back-end stuff
make something cool and open source at
yourself which is this grade school
science project with popsicle sticks and
tape and wires because when you do that
the first point of contact for use your
peers and people that respect you as a
human being you're going to give you
constructive constructive criticism
which is a billion times more helpful
than randos being jerks so these are my
cats their names are Rick Deckard and
reset smith rick is fat and reset is
very handsome I like cats a lot I've
been talking about building a cat feeder
bought forever to the point that I think
I just annoyed some of my friends and
they were like just do you have to do it
so you shut up about it from past j/s
comps in Florida I had loved my brief
experience with the node box community
it's so friendly and really helpful the
documentation is amazing and all the
people are really great and plus there's
slack channels there's get er channels
people even answer you on Twitter even
when you sometimes don't want them to
it's like excessively helpful so I
decided to build a node-based cat feeder
that works over the web and that's this
thing and it is robo kitty here's my
cats again
that's reset I said he was handsome and
that's fabric so the tech that I picked
for this project was no jeaious Johnny 5
which is a JavaScript robotics library
socket i/o and then when I was trying to
decide what microcontrollers to use I I
struggled a little bit first I I wanted
the Arduino Uno because it already has
that Internet connectivity no it does
not and that's why it didn't work so I
grabbed the Arduino you which does have
the Internet connectivity but it wasn't
compatible with Johnny 5 and then I
finally settled on particle photon so I
spent a lot of money so you don't have
to UM the part list for this is a
typical dry goods dispenser which I got
on amazon it's the kind that they put
cereal in at hotels for continental
breakfast it's about twenty dollars a
particle photon kit with a breadboard
which also runs like twenty thirty
dollars a continuous servo which is
taped on to the front and a four double
a battery pack with on/off switch which
I would not recommend instead figure out
how to plug it in because that thing
eats batteries like crazy and a
miscellaneous harp and miscellaneous
hardware accessories that I use our male
to male jumper wires which are for
connecting the breadboard to the servo
and I had to solder a little bit and
some heat-shrink so never having worked
with any of this stuff before i bought
it all and I'm at home I kind of have an
idea in my head of like how it's going
to work from point A to point B and then
I'm like this otter trying to like put
all the pieces together and I was like I
really i don't i don't know what I'm
doing I mean in short like things pretty
pretty much one smoothly except that
electricity scares me I don't understand
Ohm's law at all so I thought that I was
going to constantly electrocute myself
which wouldn't really be possible even
with the amount of power coming through
there now that I know I also didn't
realize that I needed to externally
power the servo I was like all right
this microcontroller has power so if i
plug this into the microcontroller then
it should work right no it doesn't i
also had no idea how to solder when i
began now I know how to solder I'm
really good at it but um so what I did
is I went on YouTube and I googled how
to solder as you do when you don't know
how to do something and the video
results that I got was a very helpful
doomsday prepper he was wearing full
camouflage he had I don't know probably
like ready to eat MRE food rations and
he was just like take this wire you take
this wire and he didn't even like try
and preach about any other things it was
really great so then I was ready to test
the code was working awesome i'm using
cronjob currently because i wanted to
not only have it dispensed food
immediately i also wanted it to be timed
there's better ways to do it you can
open a pull request if you want to fix
it for me and the server was strong
enough to turn the feeder handle which i
was a little bit worried about if you
have it totally full is food gonna come
out so everything's working great except
it wouldn't stop at all if you push the
button like everything that was in there
would just keep on coming out on all
over the floor and like fatrick loves
that but that's like the opposite of
what I wanted to happen so I do what I
always do when that something doesn't
work which if you follow me on Twitter
I'm sure you saw this morning because I
couldn't get it to work I started
freaking out I just like yell and I'm
like why what's happening I'm sad it's
probably Rick Waldron's fault cuz it's
fun to blame things on him it wasn't
this time it was that time though but I
looked my peers for help like I
mentioned before the get er chat was
amazing Brooklyn jas which is where i'm
from made a no BOTS room so i would stop
bothering them in dms people reviewed my
code actually soos who's talking
tomorrow reviewed my code and she was
like nothing's wrong it looks great and
then I was like well what's happening
but then something awesome happened it
was a bug in Johnny 5 and it was Rick
Waldron's fault
so I I tweeted the code from my
automated feeder is done if I didn't
already have a cat named Rick I'd name
the one after Rick Waldron and he he
found the bug he fixed it and then it
worked and that felt so good because if
somebody else wants to build it and it
didn't work that would be a huge problem
now I'm going to show you a little bit
of the server code as it was when I
first wrote it um this was my first time
trying any of this stuff so I kind of
just like dumped it into a huge file and
this was done in November and it since
evolved into way more elaborate stuff
but i'll show you this a little bit i
have like a regular node app running I
didn't have any routing at the time you
just set up your little server thing
sorry wordwrap is on but i'm not going
to scroll over this is how you set up
your board with Johnny Five and then the
cron job is really ugly but there it is
and then once it's on and connected what
it's doing is it tells the servo to stop
in case it's on already which I don't
know why it would be it's just like just
in case you're on stop and then it turns
on a little bit and goes backwards in
case there's a jam and then turns
forward again and is like yeah there's
food and it's set to New York so
obviously if you're not in New York and
you want to feed your cats on our normal
schedule you'd have to change that and
then so that's the server code and then
the client code before routing was added
in was just a plain website and it sets
it to every few hours and then clear
schedule and then there's some inline
script at the bottom and the site's
really cute because it's on theme and it
looks like this which I'll show you a
little bit later so once it works the
cats were like yeah
this is not a picture of rec I promise
so I was almost ready to open source it
I was getting really close things were
working out great and I put a call out
on Twitter for code reviews because I
wanted you know people that I trust to
check it before people tear it apart and
the response was pretty pretty
overwhelming so many people helped me
out the contributions went from like
just me like sad at my coffee table
because my apartments not big enough for
a dining room table to like a ton of
contributions they added in a routing
ave refactor did there's like an NPM
module I don't even know if it's done um
but yeah they had they helped a lot and
then I was I just told you all this and
they review the readme for language
that's like the biggest part of this
project since I didn't know what I was
doing when I started I wanted to write
the readme as if someone that had no
idea what they were doing technically
could go in and get the code and do
everything step by step so I made no
assumptions it's really long and
honestly writing language that was
accessible to anyone without like
guessing what their technical background
was was probably harder for me than this
whole entire project but I wanted
somebody if they were interested in it
to have the same experience that I had
when I was interested in no bots and be
able to just like pick things and then
go find out how to do it and be able to
set it all up and after they did all
this for me like the most exciting thing
for me was that they actually liked it
so I was really happy and then I got to
test it with the cats um it worked it
used to be cardboard but cardboard
doesn't travel really well and popsicle
sticks does better Rick was my tester
and we got this really cute animation of
him being like yeah it's time to eat so
it worked really well I was ready to
launch finally and what I did is I
changed the repository to public I
tweeted about it for some reason I
submitted a link to hacker news
and then I took a nap uh and and when I
woke up from my nap it was on the front
page of hacker news and people weren't
being jerks which is surprising it was
off brand but i was happy although
someone was like you could have done
this and I was like whatever you do it
I'll have two people retweeted it a lot
it's like way more than this now and
there's been some forks and requests for
it to be on different microcontrollers
which I'm going to do after this because
I spent three hours this morning trying
to get it to work and it was start a ton
it's actually over 700 now which you
know not a matter of your self-worth but
it was my first open source project so
it felt really great but the most the
best most exciting part was that I was
huge in Japan and this is like this is
like from what I can gather the the like
Japanese equivalent of TechCrunch I
guess um there's something lost in
translation they assumed that I had
never done any programming whatsoever so
that's probably why they wrote about it
they thought it was a lot cooler than it
actually was or cats who knows so the
things that I learned from this whole
project was um don't be afraid of the
unfamiliar because what you don't know
at the beginning you will know at the
end and then you'll be able to tell
other people about it and everybody wins
also uh don't be afraid to ask for help
this is something that I had struggled
with for a while due to like bad
experiences in tech but people that are
like willing to help you are are great
and then once they help you you can help
other people and it's just an endless
nice cycle of helping people really like
cats unless you don't and then why don't
downplay your abilities when I started
talking about this project I was like I
mean it's just a microcontroller turning
his servo but I probably should have
been like it's a really awesome cat
feeder and like the only person that was
probably like not the only person the
person thought it was the coolest was my
mom and she was like you should hire a
lawyer and get a patent I was like mom
that's not what open sourcing is like
and I don't care and if you saw this
thing you would not agree
also I really really really like node
BOTS there's so much fun there's so many
things that you can do with it I mean
you can pretty much pick there's a ton
of different microcontrollers and then
you're just like I want to connect a
light or a switch or a button or a
potentiometer or an accelerometer and
they'll tell you exactly how to do it
and then you can do silly things like
this and now is the moment of truth all
right let's see if this demo works give
me one second I'm gonna close this no
doubt yes it is connected localhost this
is Bravo kitty isn't it cute I'm gonna
turn the battery on and there is candy
in here so if you like candy on the
floor it's your lucky day
I'm gonna let it all right now all right
and then they have one more thing to
show you not on the feeder and it's
basically just the end of my talk so
yeah thank you I'm oh ho on twitter if
you want to contribute to the repository
at all it's rachel nicole / robo kitty
and my website is rachel is awesome with
a dot Emmy and I'm cool online for all
the weird stuff that I like to make and
please feel free to eat this candy it's
been down there for longer than five
seconds but it's probably still good
they